c'est sans équivoque la vaccination
contre la covid c'est sauf au Québec
ues
je dirais une grande campagne à travers
le Québec pour tous les gens les experts
s'entendent les doses successives de
rappel sont probablement chose du passé
pour la population générale pour les
gens qui ont déjà reçu deux doses de
vaccins ou trois doses de vaccins et qui
pour ceux qui ont plus en fait la covid
la chance que vous finissiez à l'hôpital
avec une maladie sévère et quasiment
nulle moi je pense que le virus est
encore présent la preuve c'est que
beaucoup de gens consultent à l'hôpital
même pour les 65 ans et plus en bonne
santé qui ont reçu quatre ou cinq doses
la vaccination deviendra peut-être
annuelle dans un futur rapproché
d'ajouter comme ça à chaque 5-6 mois une
autre dose
apporte seulement un bénéfice marginal
les experts soutiennent que les
personnes plus vulnérables immunos
supprimées ou très âgées devront
cependant continuer à être protégés ce
sont eux qui je trouve actuellement sont
sous vaccinés aussi et ce sont eux qu'on
peut réellement protéger avec des doses
de rappel plus fréquentes c'est une
bonne nouvelle pour ceux qui en veulent
pas puis qui croient on va dire pas
d'autres choses mais
qui pensent que leur système immunitaire
est assez fort pour combattre tout ça
dans mon cas ça a été le cas par contre
pour ceux qui n'ont jamais été vaccinés
ou qui n'ont jamais attrapé la covid une
dose de vaccin de ma recommandé ces
gens-là sont plus à risque de
complications pour ce qui est du variant
xbb.1.5 qui frappe les États-Unis le
docteur Weiss ne s'en fait pas trop on
devrait pas à mon sens paniqué chaque
fois qu'elle nous varie nouveau variant
arrive si vous voulez dans notre
environnement les recommandations
finales du Comité sur les municipations
du Québec devrait être dévoilées dans
les prochains jours ce sera ensuite au
gouvernement de décider si oui ou non
les citoyens seront appelés à recevoir
une autre dose de vaccin ici
Pierre-Alexandre Bolduc Radio-Canada
Québec